Thanks a lot.
I got to talk for just a couple of
minutes and Alan will talk for a couple of
minutes and then we will entertain your
questions and, and a have discussion.
Uh, it's a thrill for us to, to be here
talking to you guys about, um, this, uh,
this book chasing New Horizons and the,
uh,
the mission and the effort
that led up to the mission, uh,
that finally after a long journey,
much of which was spent
on earth. Um, we, uh,
finally made it to Pluto.
Um,
and of course Google is a part of
this story in, in various ways.
In fact, um, one of the really
cool things that happened after,
uh, the, uh, finally, uh, the, the, uh,
success of the, um, of the
mission with achieved and,
and our new horizons made
it to Pluto was that, um,
that there was a Google doodle, um, about
the new horizons mission are really,
really cool. One of the next
day was one of that, you know,
part of the global outpouring of,
uh,
of interest that reflected back on the
team that had, that had achieved this.
And of course the, um, the
conductivity of the world that,
that your company has been been so much
a part of is also an interesting part of
the story because unlike other
first planetary flybys historically,
um, that happened in the,
in the late 20th century,
the flyby of Pluto happened in an age
where it could instantly be shared and
collectively experienced around the world.
And it really made the
experience different for those
of us who happened to be
there at the applied physics
laboratory in Laurel, Maryland,
where the team was, um,
controlling the spacecraft in
getting the data down. First.
It made the experience different there
because there was this reaching out to
the world and feedback coming back.
And of course it made the
experience different for,
for people around the world.
It was truly the first
21st century, um, uh,
experience of exploration
that was like that. So,
so this book chasing New Horizons, um, is,
uh, the story of, um, how
Pluto was explored in a lot of,
it's really the backstory, the, they, um,
the aspects of planetary exploration and
have this adventure that's very human
adventure that most people don't know.
Everybody knows we made it to Pluto. And,
and like you said, you know,
in a way it's like, you know,
spoiler over on the cover of the book,
there's a beautiful picture of Pluto.
So a lot of this is the drama
of will they make it w you know,
against all odds. And then of course, you
know how the story ends, but it's like,
you know, a lot of good historical
movies and novels and stories,
even though you know how it came out,
uh,
you can still be on the edge of your seat
with the drama and all the close calls.
And that's the kind of
story we tell here. Um, I,
I've been in love with
the story for a long time.
Way before there was a new horizons
mission. There was a small group,
Alan and uh,
some of his colleagues who were quite
young when they started just out of Grad
school and their 20s and 30s, who got
this idea that after voyager made it to,
to Neptune,
which was the last of the sort of previous
era of planetary exploration after
that in 1989, you know, what was next?
We had had our first vibe eyes of all
the classically known planets except for
Pluto. And these guys said, let's keep
going. And at first, uh, you know,
they had a lot of doors slammed in
their faces and a lot of doubters and
naysayers. And then as they
started going, there were a lot of,
I'm sort of near calamities and a lot
of um, seeming dead ends. But, uh,
it's really a story of
overcoming obstacles and a
team that just got fixated on
an idea and didn't give up and eventually
gathered more and more people to
realize it was a good idea, rallied
the scientific community behind it.
And there's a whole story there of how
the skepticism gave way to widespread
endorsement.
And then there are a lot of political
intrigues and it was canceled by two
successive political administrations 26
years from when Alan started working on
this to, uh, you know, started,
got the idea and started rallying people
together to the actual flyby of Pluto.
Um, so, you know,
you hear like it took nine years to
cross a solver system and that is an
impressive time and it's longer than,
you know,
most of our missions and did require
a lot of technical innovation to, uh,
succeed at that. And yet
that's like, you know,
only a small part of the long
struggle to make this happen. So,
so I was excited to tell that story
and excited to work with Allen, um,
who you know,
who lived it and,
and work together to combine our voices
and really try to narrate what is
essentially an adventure
story, sort of a Techie, nerdy,
very human adventure story. Um, and um,
it's not just Allen want to make
sure and point out, uh, you know,
he was obviously the
leader of the mission,
but there were a lot of people involved.
As Alan says, it's a team sport. And um,
so we included the voices of
a lot of other people. Um, uh,
members of the science
team, engineers, um,
some NASA officials at different people
that were involved in this history and
in this mission. So in the
book, in addition to our
narrative, you'll see a lot of,
um, a lot of Alan's voice in the
first person sort of set aside, um,
relating his experience,
but also a lot of other voices kind of
we weaving in and you'll get to know some
of the characters. So, um,
anyways, I've, I've loved this
story for a long time when,
when I got the opportunity to actually
work with Alan on this a book,
it was a dream come true for me because I,
I lived to tell stories of planetary
exploration and in my view,
there's no better story in our time of
exploration. Uh, and then of course,
Pluto itself turned out
to be just tremendous, uh,
scientifically. Aesthetically
it's beautiful. It's mysterious.
It's so much more active and
dynamic than anybody expected.
And that has taught us a lot that we
didn't know about planetary science.
And that feeds back on
just our awareness of,
of what kinds of planets there
can be in the universe in general.
So it was a huge payoff.
And, um, the, uh, you know,
the only person who knows what needed
to be known to tell the story really in
full is Alan Stern.
And it was a privilege for me to get to
work with Allen to combine our voices to
tell the story. And with that, I want to
introduce Alan to come up and, and, uh,
say a few words.
It's your
[inaudible]
that's great to be here.
Um, thank you David. Um,
I dunno how many of you know this?
David is the best writer in our
field as a planetary scientist.
No one has written a better books from
Venus revealed about the radar missions
that uncovered the geology of
Venus to Earth in human hands.
His most recent work before,
before chasing and, uh,
and quite a number of others.
And it's been a privilege for me.
We've known each other a long time in a
lot of different modes over the years.
Uh, since we met, he lived
in boulder for a long time.
And then in Denver where I'm based, the
used to be my boss too. There's that too.
That's true. Um, so, um,
this is a really interesting story.
I hope you get a chance to read it and
I hope people watching on video get a
chance to read it.
Um,
when I was a boy, I was swept off my
feet by the early planetary explorations.
All I ever wanted to do was grow
up and get through. You know,
I'm 11 years old and just the idea of
going to college is like the light year in
the future and wanted to go to
college and then I found out, oh,
you have to go to graduate school.
Then I went to graduate school
for different times. Um, but um,
at the time I emerged in 1989 with my phd.
Um,
voyager was finishing and all the
planets from mercury to Neptune had been
explored at least first reconnaissance.
Pluto was kind of unfinished,
unfinished business and
scientifically fascinating.
We knew that it had an atmosphere and
a giant satellite that made it a double
planet.
We'd never been to anything like that.
We knew that it's surface
composition was really exotic.
We knew a number of really enticing,
very basic facts,
but I think you could put them
all on a three by five card. Um,
but to be a planetary scientist at
the beginning of the age of space
exploration,
the most prized mission is to be on,
we're always the first missions.
Only the best got to be on the first
missions to Mars or Venus or Jupiter or
mercury or on down the line. And those
are the missions were scientifically,
you can say the result is like
taking candy from a baby, right?
Everything. Every image is, is
just big news. Every spectrum,
every data type.
And
for me and for my generation, Pluto is the
last train to Clarksville. That's like,
that's the only one.
When do we get a chance to be on something
that momentous and voyager was just
finishing and we thought, well of
NASA is in the exploration business.
This will be a cinch.
This will be a 15 minute conversation.
Who wouldn't want to make the first
mission to the last planet? Right?
And 14 years later we finally achieve
funding after crazy experiences,
which you'll read about you.
This book is really, you know,
if you picture like DNA double helix
picture like heck to helix or something,
because the book is the political
story of how this all came to be.
And it's the scientific story of why
it was important to do and how it was
transformed by the discovery of the Kuiper
belt into being the first mission to
the third zone of the solar system
and then these fantastic results.
But it's also an under the hood.
Look at how you build.
What we had to do was we had a big,
basically rebuild voyager much lighter
and much faster and you'll appreciate
this. I think that some of the projects
you do, we had to do it in half the time.
And one fifth the cost.
So we had to make a lot of innovations,
took 2,500 men and women. I realize that
Google, that's a hobby shop project,
but a lot of people worked on this
and they worked very hard, um,
under the gun with what some
folks thought were impossible.
Boundary conditions.
I know when we want it,
we want it against the Goliath
of planetary exploration.
Our team wanted against JPL,
the jet propulsion lab at Caltech
who had been first to every plant,
the solar system. We wrote the better
proposal. We marketed it better.
We did have the better team.
And Nasa I think made the right
choice because I do think, um,
it's uncertain to me whether they,
the guys could have pulled it
off given all the constraints.
They were really old school
and we were new school,
but they were talented group and I had
many friends on those competing teams.
And nonetheless, we got it.
And when we want it, um,
and I can't tell you how many phone
calls I got from friends that were
colleagues and said, you won, but you
lost. And that story's in the book.
David wrote the book because they'd
say, you know, great, you've won.
You're now in charge of the mission
to Pluto that we'll never get launched
because you will either, you'll fail
on schedule, it won't be your fault.
It will be some vendor somewhere, you
know, some critical part you need.
Or you won't get nuclear launch approval
because no one's done it ever in four
years or even close, you know, that's
42 state and federal agencies, you know,
if you, you guys use the phrase we
use about her hurting cats. Yeah,
this is different. This is cats hurting
themselves. It's a whole nother lives,
like three dimensional chess. So, uh,
uh, and then people would say, well,
what do you mean a 20% of the
two dimes on the dollar in?
You're never going to figure that out and
get it done in one of these traps will
bite you.
You might get through some of these hoops,
but you'll never get through all of them.
And fortunately,
our team was very dedicated,
dedicated to nights and weekends. Uh,
uh,
the,
the primary players were southwest
research institute where I work,
the applied physics lab,
Apl at Johns Hopkins, uh,
and Lockheed Martin
for the launch vehicle,
the Department of energy for the
nuclear power supply. Um, by the way,
because Google is a restaurant,
we used to call APL
always a pizza lunch cause the only
thing they would ever serve pizza
like I, the number of pizzas I
ate or in scientific notation.
Anyway, this, this book tells
all those stories and it's,
the stories are woven together.
The science, the politics,
the how you build this,
how you fly an interplanetary
mission across the solar system.
Some of the technologies we invented
like spacecraft, hibernation,
the navigation requirements
that were super stringent, um,
hit a 40 by 60 kilometer window from 3
billion miles away. And Oh, by the way,
and do that while arriving
within nine months,
minutes of the time you aim for when you
launched nine years before and do all
that. Um, and you only get one
shot. There's no voyager two here.
There's no new horizons to, to back
it up. There's no making a uturn.
We're going 14 kilometers a second,
get it right or go home. Um,
and it all worked out.
Although we had a near death experience,
which the book begins with July 4th,
2015 a day meant for
other kinds of fireworks.
And my cell phone rings and I
pick it up for even picking it up.
I saw it was the guy,
it's our project manager and he's not
calling me on the 4th of July because he's
having a great barbecue before he ever
got the sentence through his mouth.
You know, I could tell from the
gravity of his voice, he said, Alan,
we've lost contact with the spacecraft.
That just doesn't happen.
It's not like when your computer reboots,
right. It'll be fine in five minutes.
Um, so, um, it,
it's a really interesting read and I don't
think there's any book that's like it.
Um,
we were on the John Bachelor show in
Manhattan this weekend and he kept saying,
you wrote a movie and we hope we wrote a
movie because it's a really interesting
story and it's not just for tech heads,
but it's also a story of
drama and persistence. Uh,
by people with a dream that actually
managed despite a lot of issues along the
way to pull off what they didn't
know how to do when we started.
And I'd be happy to answer
questions if you have some, uh, and,
and talk about this, but I want to
tell one story before I stopped. Um,
I've never told this story
before. Um, but, um, uh,
I worked at NASA for a time and when
I left, this is NASA headquarters.
I ran the science program and,
uh, and that's a big enterprise.
It's about five and a half billion
dollars a year and not big by Google
standards,
but I hadn't left about 10 days and Eric
Schmidt invited me to come out to Palo
Alto for, offer me a job and I said no,
which may have made the difference between
whether we explored the Pluto system
or not. I mean, in the end.
Thank you, Eric watching. Um,
that was a really enticing
job. Um, but you know,
I'll be back on the market
after we finished exploring
the corporate belt anyway,
so I thought I'd just tell
that little anecdote. Um,
and then Dave wants to
come back up here and, uh,
I don't know if I was just
books been out less than a week,
so probably no one in
the room has read it.
But if you have any questions
about planetary exploration,
certainly astrobiology uh, or uh, Pluto,
the Kuiper belt or new
horizons have at it.
You know,
I just have to say,
one of the great things about working
with Alan on this book is that, uh,
he got a lot of great stories and we,
uh,
the first step of us writing this book
together was we talked to every Saturday
really for a year and a half.
And he just told me stories and I asked
him questions and we figured out the
structure of the book and uh, um,
but I never heard that story before.
That's a new, there are a lot
of stories. Yeah. Anyways,
we can put in a thousand page book and
know, do you guys want to know? Yeah,
so obviously there was a ton of
build up to actually launching,
but once it actually launched,
what was that?
Nearly a decade waiting like every day.
You have to check in and make adjustments
or is it manages itself and you just
stress for nine years.
Explain what that's like.
Um, the most succinct answer would
be yes to all those things. Um,
it was intimidating to think about nine
and a half years when we first launched
it.
That just seemed to me like forever.
I mean on my 12 year is going to be 21,
I can't even picture Jordan 21.
Uh, that kind of thing. And I
think all of us felt that way. Um,
one thing people don't know and the
book does describe it is that, um,
while people think that, you know, Oh,
a lot of people know the spacecraft
was hibernating so they think we were
hibernating. We had nothing to do.
But let me put this in context.
When voyager flew across the solar system,
they had a staff of 450 people run the
spacecraft to do the science team or the
management to do everything.
My team was large when
we were building it,
but within a month of launching it,
we let everybody go.
We didn't need a launch
vehicle team anymore.
We didn't need the
department of energy anymore.
We don't need a big engineering
kid is nothing off to build.
We just put a lot of spares and controlled
inventory and we had already done all
the documentation and we just
kept some engineering leads.
And so we were 50 people.
That's like the number of people in
this room to do every part of it.
From the flight controllers to the
engineers, to the science team,
to the management team, to
the public affairs, all that.
And uh, we were incredibly
busy. There's a chapter,
it's one of my couple of favorites in
the whole book called Battle Plan Pluto
where we tell the story
of how you actually plan.
I'm a fly by like this where the
spacecraft is operating completely burned,
no control,
all the software and all the support files
have to be completely tested in every
way you can think of.
And how we had to plan for fly bys
because we were worried we would find
hazards, debris that can strike
the spacecraft on approach.
So we picked different aim points
and we could choose among them,
but the point at which you would choose
was so close to the moment of fly by
that you had to have the software
on the shelf. There was no,
oh now we'll write a different plan.
Each plan takes like a
year to develop and test,
so we had to do this four
times and on top of it we had,
we put intelligent software up on the
bird that could detect 160 something
faults.
The fuel was leaking at the computers,
getting bad messages for this
or that. We lost comm, whatever,
and then we'd run down a checklist.
It could even as it ran down the checklist
decision in branch based upon data.
So it would act as if you
had a crew member on board.
We had to write and test all that stuff.
We conducted mission simulations in
which we fake the clocks out on the,
on the bird in flight in the middle
of nowhere between Uranus and Neptune.
It thinks it's 2015 it's doing
nine days of every pointing.
We ship all that data back and makes
sure every star field is exactly the one
you intended, right? Um, every instrument
was operating at the right voltage,
every little thing. Um, we had 40 mission
simulations, the bottom line, all this,
and I'm only telling you
part of the story is, um,
we worked our butts off for
nine years. Um, Alice Bowman,
who's the woman who runs up my
mission control, um, you know,
many times came to me and said,
this is too much work for this team.
We have to take content out. We've
got a separate icing from cake. And,
and she called it a nine and
a half year sprint. Right?
It was tough and the spacecraft was
hibernating a lot, but this little team,
um,
it was,
it was incessant and all of a sudden
Pluto was there and a lot of people were
coming and saying, wait a minute,
can we put the brakes on? You know,
I actually don't want, want to save her
this. It's coming too fast. So thanks.
That's a great question. By the
way. They, the hibernation, um,
that Allen mentioned was itself a really,
uh,
innovative part of this mission.
That was a brilliant solution to how do
you have a spacecraft traveling for nine
and a half years and not be
worn out when you get there.
And also have the human resources to do
all that planning and simulating that
Allen was talking about
with a really small team.
It was part of how they
answered this question,
how do we do something on a tiny
fraction of voyagers budget?
And that allowed them to have a smaller
ground him cause they weren't running
the spacecraft the whole time,
but it was,
it was something they had
to learn how to do that.
And we talk about that in the book.
They practice hibernation at first
they put it to sleep for, you know,
a couple of days and then a week and
then a month to make sure that it works.
And that innovation and,
and a lot of the other ones they came up
with are now part of space exploration
and other missions are using them.
Uh, just say one thing and then
I'll call on this gentleman,
but you got to ask me before the,
you all came in the room about how long
it took to get the data to the ground.
You know, the dirty little secret is
we did that to save money is we have,
we intentionally chose that. If you
could take nine years to reach Pluto,
you could spend one more year
to get all the data back.
Voyager was seventies
technology at Neptune almost
as far as Pluto head anytime
right there behind you, a little two
meter addition, Tenet, small. We,
we had one 10th the data rate of voyager
intentionally because we realize what
an enormous cost savings
it was. You say, well,
how much cheaper can a smaller antenna
beat? It's not the antenna. He said, well,
how much cheaper can you know?
Lower powered transmitter speed.
They save you millions,
but millions is small in an 800 and
something million dollar project.
What it really was, was that if
we had lower power transmitters,
I could graduate down from to like voyager
to one nuclear power supply and those
babies cost 80 million a piece.
So by,
by accepting lower data rates,
we made this very intelligent compromise
that we would take a whole year and a
little more to get the data back
in exchange for the, you know,
that's almost a hundred
million dollars right there.
So there were a bunch of those and we talk
about them. Sorry for the detour. Yes.
Um,
in your opinion,
what was the scientific knowledge
we gained about Pluto or
of having these kind of,
Oh God,
which 1:00 AM I right
children
because thought is okay, so we got,
doesn't have what doesn't have a core,
that's all interesting piece of
information but not as shocking,
but you know what, fuck
this. Appreciate it.
Yeah. Um, I don't think there's an
answer to that actually. You know,
different people would say different
things. And there's a third thing too,
and actually the book ends,
the last two and a half pages is a Coda
to the book that actually talks about
the biggest impact and the greatest
discovery was how much it affected people.
Just people just inspired people
to stem careers and was, you know,
a moonshot for a new
generation of, uh, of,
uh, millennials basically
and how it affected them. So,
but all those things are good.
We don't have to choose between them.
We've got all the scientific knowledge,
all the breakthroughs and how you do
low cost space flight to the planets.
We got all the engineering advances
and we got all the inspiration.
So there's no reason to
rank them there. Yeah.
And you never have one without the other
because without the motivation for the
exploration,
you're not going to have a mission
with all that technical innovation.
But without all the technical innovation,
you're not going to have a mission and
get the science. But, but you know,
it wasn't just odd has
a core or something.
It actually was fundamental
what we've learned there and,
and changed our paradigms and will truly,
it sounds like a cliche,
but we truly require textbooks
to be rewritten because
we did not expect a small
planet on the fringes of the solar
system to be so geologically active and
diverse and vibrant and,
and parts of it to be quite young
and still currently forming.
And that was something we
had to, you know, go back to
the drawing boards and now,
um, have some provisional
explanations. But that, you know,
that's how that's really
what drives science, uh,
is this exploration that then leads
to results that, uh, you know,
that shows us that our prediction and
our previous knowledge was wrong and
requires us to really a re reinvent
our theories of planetary evolution.
And New Horizons has done that.
You might say, you know, you might
imagine this, but as a science team,
everybody want to make predictions.
And we actually had a poll and we,
we had a meeting a couple months before
the fly by and one of my postdocs,
Amanda's and gory, ran the pole. There
were like 30 questions and you know,
we had a little little team
that put together the questions,
everybody answered them and we put
the results in the computer of course,
and we're plotting the distribution of
the histogram of how many satellites do
you think we will find or how many
people think that we'll find evidence for
active volcanism on the surface or
whatever the questions were. And so, uh,
and then we showed that to everybody.
And then a couple of months after the
flyby when we had enough data to sort of
understand the lay of the land,
um,
I scored that against the
real Pluto and it was pitiful.
And so like I gave the team, I
literally passed out report cards. Yes.
And they gave all A's for exploration and
F's for scientific predictive ability.
Yes. Yeah. Firstly, thank you
for the monkeys reference.
Is the,
your subtitle optimistic about first
mission or do you know of upcoming
missions?
Oh, both. Both. Both. And
we actually almost, we had a
debate about whether, I mean,
there's only been one mission,
so I would just say first, right.
It's just the epic mission to
Pluto. Isn't that enough? Um, uh,
but first it's one of those words
that it's like an Seo thing, right?
It's got to get people to look at it.
Um,
but we do expect that there
will be more missions because I,
and we originally thought that this was,
that we could go in with 21st century
instrumentation and accomplish and we did
about the equivalent of the first 20 years
of Mars exploration in one fell swoop.
Uh, and we did, but we
learned many things that are,
make my head hurt.
And so w we're working very hard to see
an orbiter fly there and follow up and I
think there'll be now other missions to
small planets in the Kuiper belt because
we want to sample the diversity
of this new population.
I think if Pluto was that interesting and
some of the things we know from ground
based and the huddle soon
we'll know from James Webb. Um,
I think that will also want to look at,
at some of the others for comparison.
So I expect there'll be
a lot more of this. Yes.
The risk of being a little bit
to weigh in on the merits of manned
space exploration versus for Monica space
exploration.
And I,
I asked this one is because we living
in a positive in front of the country
as citizens get to me in on where
we put our dollars. Do you think,
do you think the public's perception of
this is aligned with your perception of
this?
Oh, well that's a different question,
but I will weigh in and I was,
so you said weigh in on the merits of
robotic space flight versus human space
flight. Right. So I might translate
that question to an equivalent question.
Would you please weigh in for me on the
merits of a knife and fork and a spoon
at the table?
Um,
my point is they're all different tools
for different purposes and at the table
you really need all three. It's really
hard to do your soup with a fork and it's,
it's really hard to cut your steak
with just the spoon or the fork.
And so human space flight and robotic
space flight are really very different
tools.
I don't know anybody in this time that
would say you need human space flight to
do weather satellites, communication
satellites and a lot of the applications,
but it's still the case that
humans make much better, um,
field analysis teams then
the rovers that we have now,
Apollo teams would cover about as much
ground scientifically in a three day
expedition as a rover mission
can't in five years. Uh,
and they can make on the spot
discoveries that robots can. Um,
so I think we need both all
the tools and the, you know,
we're not going to be sending
people to Pluto anytime soon. Um,
but on the other hand,
at places like the moon and Mars and
maybe series and smaller asteroids,
the humans can really push the pedal to
the metal and the humans do something.
Even though new horizons was a good
example of being inspirational,
it's hard for the 23rd
mission to Mars for that,
that particular robot to
really light people's fire.
Whereas when we send men and women,
it,
it will be unbelievable in
terms of the worldwide response.
And that's what fuels the tech economy
in a space as the gateway drug to
engineering and science careers.
Well dinosaurs too,
but the dinosaurs always lose.
Right? So it's really space.
Who else?
Yes.
How long did it take after march for you
read the paper or see a tech report and
wish that was something you had had
on board?
Yes.
So we've talked about that too.
And,
and so the two ways to look at that and
the only realistic way to look at it is
given the, the boundary conditions
on money and schedule and the,
and the Arrow that we built
it between 2001 and five,
what would you do differently?
That means a zero sum game.
You have to find the money, the mass, the
resources by taking something else off.
And,
uh,
there's no instrument or capability on
New Horizons that we wish we would trade,
that we would lose in order to do
something else. Now with the orbiter,
which will be a much more capable
spacecraft in a much, um, uh,
a wider variety of payloads on board
instruments will do lots of things we
couldn't do with a simple fly by,
but I wouldn't trade anything if
I really could just, you know,
have my wish it would have been that we
had enough money to fly to because the
far side of Pluto and its satellites is,
you know,
we can only see them for
millions of kilometers away
as we were screaming up and
then they turned away.
And it's frustrating.
You look at the other side of Pluto
and it looks completely different and
fascinating. And what does that
have to teach us, you know, and, uh,
I'm really betting on life extension so
that I can be Pii. That next mission.
Yeah.
Right here
it was a publicly funded, at a timeless,
not clear what the future holds for that.
Um,
what do you think is likely to happen?
What do you think should happen in terms
of public versus private funding for
this thing?
Well, fortunately, and everybody here
probably knows this, this is that, um,
uh,
commercial spaces coming on very strong.
And I admit I am a very highly biased and
also happened to be the board chair of
the commercial spaceflight federation,
which is the industry of
Federation that blue origin and,
and space x and everybody else's in
80 corporations from small mom and pop
almost shops, you know, all the way
up to space x and blue origin. Uh,
uh, but I think again, it's not a
choice between one and the other. Um,
this is a huge solar system
with dozens of worlds.
And you know, I, I don't,
I don't know how we would,
we would do all the things that we do
on the season in the air if it was all
done by just the air force and
the navy. Right. And besides,
if it's one organization,
you can't possibly have the
level of innovation that
you get through competition.
And so I think all that's going on at
places like blue origin and SpaceX and all
the others is it's finally the 21st
century where we don't just have one space
program but lots of them. And
now we're starting to have, uh,
the asteroid miners and the moon miners
and lots more applications being talked
about. And I think the 20s are
going to be just spectacular,
but also what NASA is going to be doing
in the 20s, which you would not see. Um,
uh, uh, commercial enterprise is
exploring Europa for scientific knowledge,
but you might see commercial
enterprises sending payloads to Mars,
uh, because they can, uh, they can find
customers that want to fly those now.
So sort of the vanguard,
the leading edge I think is always going
to be the government in most respects.
Um, but, uh, private
industries, what comes in and,
and really turns it into part
of the economy and what we do.
And we need both.
And nobody at NASA that I know,
we both know a lot of people at NASA.
I know nobody. There is a,
you know, bummed out that, oh,
now that we have these competitors
from frappe from private industry,
they're like, oh great, you know,
we don't have to be the trucking
service up to orbit or the bus service,
you know, we can focus on other
things that only NASA can do. And um,
so the private public partnership is
really being sought by both sides in that
equation and is shaping up to really
accelerate space space exploration in the
in this century.
Yeah.
And Jim Bryden Stein,
who the new NASA administrator really
gets it with public private partnerships.
I think he's going to be great.
I'm left handed,
so I've been biasing to this side of the
room. Is there any question over here?
Yes. Um, so this is not
the only recent, uh,
exploratory mission to an IFI body in
the solar system because we also had the
Rosetta probe, uh, to the comment. I
was wondering if there was anything,
especially in the astrobiology factor,
maybe that stood out like that was
surprisingly different or suppressing the
same between Pluto and the
comic. His name, I forgot. Well,
can I just say Jeremy Knauff gear?
Reza Minka
very nicely done. Well, I was on the
Rosetta mission. Yeah. 22 years. Yeah.
So we do call it CG. It was
too much. So, so Alan can,
I can probably comment,
you know,
more in a more sophisticated way about
the comments since he's on that mission.
But I will say from an
astrobiology perspective,
one of the amazing things about
new horizons and Pluto is the, uh,
evidence that there is an ocean of liquid
water beneath the icy crust of Pluto.
Uh, it seems like there, there's
circumstantial evidence that, you know,
there are features of the planet that
are easiest to explain if there is a
liquid water ocean.
And one of the things that would
definitely to do with this orbiter Alan's
talking about if we go back,
is map the,
the gravity field and do other things
to really make sure we understand that
that's true. But it seeming like
there is an ocean of liquid water,
which is amazing from an astrobiology
perspective because any place where
there's an ocean of water is a candidate
for extra terrestrial life. So,
just as you've heard about Europa and
Enceladus as possible homes for life
underneath the ice, we really have
to add, plead out to that list now.
Yeah. And you know, keep in mind,
so I was Pi of the ultraviolet
spectrometer and Rosetta. Okay.
So we won that project in the beginning
of 1996 and flight mission and in 2016
and actually the data analysis part
of the project is still ongoing. Um,
but you know,
the comments CG,
the one with all the syllables is about
the size of Cambridge mass and Pluto is
the surface area,
the United States.
So it's a different scale and the kind of
science you're doing is very different.
What else?
Yup. What, what's like the biggest, um,
what was the most frustrating mistake
that you look back on of like, oh,
we didn't do this right if I need
to go back and change one thing.
What was the biggest takeaway?
Wow, that's a good question.
Um, I honestly, the way,
the thing that nearly killed the
spacecraft 10 days out, but it,
sure it brought a lot of viewership
the last minute.
And all of a sudden it's life or death.
What,
there were some other mistakes that, that,
that, uh, we described in the book, but,
you know, fortunately none of them were
fatal because we have a success story.
Right? So, but I mean, but they're
illustrative. There was that, uh,
you know,
I mean,
one thing you learn in this book is
how carefully everything was checked by
independent teams and you know,
like just a lot of amazing troubleshooting
and very little slip through.
But there was one
spreadsheet where, um, one,
a thruster had the wrong specs and was
built and flown with the wrong specs so
that it was going to fire too many times,
uh,
and exhausted lifetime
before they got to put out.
And they discovered this when they were
in flight and they were able to, uh,
to make some work arounds.
But that was a,
that was sort of almost the exception
that proves the rule because there were,
so,
it was almost nothing like that,
but it was really illustrative of why
it was so important that they do all the
ridiculous amount of checking
and double checking, uh, console.
So little slip through, but
that, that was, you know,
it made me not the worst mistake, but
it's an illustrative mistake. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Um, I'm really, I'm sorry,
I really don't have a good answer because
most of the things that I think I did
wrong or we did wrong actually
in the end worked out better.
So for example,
if I could do it again,
some of the things I was doing in the 90s
to lead the effort to get a mission to
Pluto, I think now with more experience,
I could've made it happen, but,
but then I would've just been a bit
player on that mission instead of been to
lead the whole thing.
So I don't want to make that happen.
So it was a lot more fun. Yeah. You Go,
I have a question with regards again and
lot of the story here in force around
politics and political struggle.
And I was wondering the fact that Pluto
at some point was demoted or was it part
of a political game?
How can you explain?
I don't think it was a
political game. Um, there,
there are really two
things that were going on.
One is I think appreciated
by a lot of people,
which is I think especially here you
have this fixation, no astronomers,
not planetary scientists,
different expertise. When I
give a public talk, you know,
I say neurologists and podiatrist's don't
go to one for problem with the other,
right, different expertise. But people
in the public, including my own mother,
confuses that all astronomers must know
everything about everything in space.
They were really trying to cope with
large numbers of planet discoveries and
thinking in a 20th century way.
I would say that the number of planets
should be small so children can remember
their names, right? Um,
um, they should have,
I wish that they'd just been consistent
and not gone on for an head motions.
They'd voted on other things they don't
know about and just gone ahead and
legislate it. We're only also going to
have eight elements in eight states now,
but,
but they didn't.
So the press picked up on it and the press
is also naively took it as expertise,
you know,
and,
and sort of made it a feta complete when
people like David and myself and others
in planetary science and joining
profession of a different expertise,
never said that and don't buy it and don't
even by the idea of voting in science
because it's sort of an
illegitimate process, right?
We could all vote that, um,
three of evolution is wrong.
It doesn't matter how many
Nobel laureates vote for it.
That doesn't mean that the data
doesn't support the theory. Okay. Um,
the other thing that was going on,
and it's very rarely discussed,
but it's the fact is that in 1980
on astronomer named Brian Marsden,
who was very accomplished,
had a very public tiff with the man who
discovered Pluto named Clyde Tombow.
And he, he actually said at a
meeting in front of a lot of people,
you're older than me, and when you're
gone, I will erase your legacy.
And Marsden is the person that led the
IAU that week to pass that resolution,
uh, which took Pluto off the
strong hummers list. And so
there's a lot of bad blood.
And if you look at the specific
technical description in,
in the IAU Aaus attempt to
at redefining planet, uh,
just from a of scientific
quantitative perspective,
it doesn't make any sense. It they
did a sloppy job. Well for one thing,
they set a planet has to orbit the Sun.
They ignored all the exoplanets
is ridiculous. But also,
even within our own solar system, they
have this criteria that a planet must,
a supposedly they said
it must clear it zone.
So they define the planet in terms of
what orbits around it and not its own
intrinsic properties.
And that leads to some very silly,
absurd conclusions like that earth was
not a planet for its first 500 million
years because it was orbiting in a
swarm of material left over from the
formation of the sun. And if you took
earth today and move to somewhere else,
say out in the asteroid belt or something,
it would not be a planet. Um, so there,
there are a lot of just sort of
unsatisfying aspects of the definition.
So it certainly made sense to,
um,
to talk about classifying Pluto and other
small planets like it as a different
subclass of planets dwarf
planets that that's fine.
But then they sort of added this and a
dwarf planet is not a planet and it was
kind of vindictive and
nonsensical. And, uh,
so in planetary science at our meetings,
you'll hear us referring to Pluto
as a planet. Um, and you know,
we almost kind of don't really even want
to want to talk about this except for,
I mean,
it is worth talking about because people
are confused in and they want to know
and so we have to try to clarify it. He
said, we don't want to talk about it,
but yesterday in the Washington
Post, two of us had an op Ed. Yeah.
How many plants are there on
your list? Oh, I'm comfortable.
So yeah, that's really the answer. No.
So I'll known it's in the mid twenties
in our solar system, in our solar system.
But of course there are thousands
of known planets around other stars,
but you know, who cares? You know,
there's countless mountains and rivers
and stars and asteroids and galaxies and
all those things, you know, spaces
all about Oh, astronomical numbers.
So we really need to get over the notion,
the notion that there were
small number of planets,
I think is equivalent to like some,
somebody who grew up on a desert island
where they were accountable number of
palm trees.
And you think that's it for the world
because you don't see any other islands.
So you know,
they're all over the rise and then you
develop the technology for ocean travel,
right? And you can now go to other places
and you discover that all those trees,
you gave them names, right? There's
so many. You can't name them all.
So you decide those aren't actually
palm trees for whatever reason,
just to keep it small. So
it's kind of crazy. Okay.
I guess we're going to
say thank you for that.
[inaudible].